bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors le taux
d'incidence un gène le dire n'a jamais
était aussi élevé à la réunion on est
une augmentation d'à peu près 20% en une
semaine omicron est il le seul
responsable de cette flambée épidémique
bonsoir effectivement à la réunion nous
subissons actuellement la vague qu il
est à la réunion actuellement c'est le
grand delta qui est prédominant nouveau
subissons depuis environ un mois au
micro niveau micro n'ont pas soumis aux
rigueurs la région alors on n'a jamais
le dire aussi on a un couvre feu
nocturne qui est donc de retour à la
réunion et cela pour faire diminuer la
pression hospitalière sur place quelle
est la situation au niveau des hôpitaux
est ce que vous savez quelle est la
proportion des cas qu'ovide qui occupent
les lits de réanimation
effectivement la mesure de couvre feu à
se ré par le préfet de la réunion était
attendu à raison comme vous l'avez
signalé à une augmentation de la
pression hospitalière dans le
département de la réunion actuellement
nous disposons de 89 lits de réanimation
84 lits sont occupés et parmi ces 90
presque la moitié sont liées à des
patients commises alors vous parlez du
préfet on devait les citer 1 nous sommes
aujourd'hui un tournant pour la
préservation du système de santé sur
notre territoire est ce que le coc vide
a mis en lumière les failles du système
de santé sur l'hymne des failles qui
était déjà existantes avant la crise
sanitaire
le point essentiel c'est contrairement
aux autres départements de métropole la
réunion il est donc en cas de besoin de
renfort il est difficile de les avoir
rapidement et s'il faut faire des
transferts ça me gave la métropole c'est
plus de onze heures d'avion donc vous
comprenez bien qu'il est important de
préserver l'état sanitaire du
département pour éviter justement des
situations incontrôlables alors on a un
couvre-feu nocturne pendant trois
semaines manifestement est ce que vous
savez dans combien de temps on va
pouvoir
voir les effets de ce couvre feu
ils ont qu'aujourd'hui on prend des
mesures c'est seulement dans dix quinze
jours quand on verra les effets comme
vous savez nous venons pas de passer
d'une période de fêtes et certainement
malgré les recommandations faites ici à
sa nombre de personnes n'ont pas
respecté les mesures barrières et donc
c'est seulement dans dix jours qu'un
jour on aura la propension
l'augmentation du taux de kobe de la
réunion suite à ces périodes de fêtes et
si les effets en son temps suffisants
qu'elles mesurent entre selon vous
serait la plus à même de limiter la
propagation du virus
alors l'eau la dernière vague la réunion
a bénéficié du soutien des personnels de
santé de métropole mais comme vous
l'avez dit et toute la métropole est
impacté par le cos vide et donc la
réunion doit en mettre en place de
mesures pour les cx de se suffire à elle
même et si elle ne se fit pas elle même
il faudra refaire ce qui s'est passé au
moins une fois l'an dernier un bac c'est
à dire organiser des avions sanitaires
pour transporter plusieurs personnes en
réanimation de saint denis de la réunion
a en métropole patrick allemand merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes colonel et
médecin chef du sdis 974 martial